leaving things to your kids doesn't
benefit them for a variety of reasons
leaving it to someone in general or
giving it to someone in general when
someone hasn't earned it tends to alter
their behavior in a negative way so how
many people have seen like the trust
fund kids that just completely lose
their minds spend you know all their
money and get into drugs because they
have no challenge they have no hardships
everything has been removed from their
lives and then basically the real
hardship becomes themselves we benefit
from struggle on a character development
perspective and I see money as potential
energy to be exchanged and so if you
give someone who's not prepared for a
Gob of potential energy that they did
not earn or learn how to wield it will
ultimately burn them up